[Music]
we will start this topic by eyeing the
following two graphs
of some functions you can pause the
video right now
quickly run your eyes over them and then
hear me out
describing each one of them individually
intuitively it's easy to tell that this
is a continuous function
and the other one isn't because its
graph is disconnected
and yes that's basically how we can
picturize a continuous
and a discontinuous function
a function continuous everywhere in the
domain
will be a smooth connected curve a nice
kind of a mnemonic
to think of the graph of a continuous
function is that it can be drawn
without having to lift a pencil on the
paper
as long as the pencil is in contact with
the paper we can trace
a continuous curve
what about the graph of a discontinuous
function
in the graph of the discontinuous
function we will find
gaps or perhaps a better word would be
breaks in the graph
the graph is all tidy and connected from
the left to the right
until we reach here where it breaks and
restarts from some place
below it then it rises higher above to
this point
before breaking again and so on
let's study this graph in short
these are the points on the x-axis that
is the domain of the function
where the function is discontinuous we
call them
points of discontinuity one more
interesting thing to observe
is this portion of the graph consists of
just one point
so at x3 the graph actually breaks twice
you will see this in many discontinuous
functions
so don't get too surprised moreover
we also find these little filled in
circles in the corners
and also there are unfilled circles
above or below filled ones what do they
represent
before revealing what they represent let
me divert your attention
to some other fact i will state an
important point about continuity
to clear a common misunderstanding
a function is continuous or
discontinuous
only in the domain of the function that
is only at those
x's where the function is defined
have a look at this function the graph
is as shown
there appears to be a big gap in the
graph between the numbers 2
and 4 on the x-axis in fact
there is no plot between these two
points as the function
is not defined for the numbers between 2
and 4.
the function is only defined for x's
between negative 1
and 2 including at negative 1 and 2
and also between 4 and 6 including both
4 and 6. so what can we say about the
points between
2 and 4 are they also the points of
discontinuity
a general perception that builds in our
mind when we hear the word discontinuous
makes us see any sort of gap in the
graph as discontinuity
but that's incorrect although this
function is continuous in
each subdomain taken separately we
cannot define continuity
anywhere between these two points as
they are not
in the domain of the function hence
earlier that was the reason why i was
refraining from using the word gap
as it might insinuate a horizontal gap
there is rarely a function you will see
in the topic with such huge gaps
a better way to imagine points of
discontinuity is the points
where the graph is jumping either up or
down
and these circles are made to mark the
position where the function is defined
at those points of discontinuity and
where it isn't
for instance at point x1 you can see
without any sort of mark
it will be difficult to tell if the
point with coordinates
x1 comma f of x1 is connected with the
left portion of the graph
or with the right in our language
we call them holes holes are made on the
curve at a point
to indicate a break in the graph
and a hole is filled into the mark where
the function is defined
at that particular x so this is where f
of x one is defined this is one type of
discontinuous function
and it shouldn't be surprising now that
this type is called
jump discontinuity there are two other
types of discontinuities
removable discontinuity and infinite
discontinuity
but we will leave them for some other
video
before ending this video i will leave
you with a question to ponder upon
look at this graph it kinda looks
similar to the graph of the type
removable discontinuity which is saw now
so the question is is this function
continuous
at x equal to negative one
share your answers with your reasons in
the comment section below
also do subscribe to our channel to stay
connected
and as always stay smart stay curious
[Music]